of times that the International Criminal
Court should either be reformed or
African countries should leave did you
discuss this issue with Chancellor
Angela Merkel no we didn't discuss that
particular issue is it not important to
get the support of countries like
Germany and France if you want to reform
the ICC well like I said this wasn't
necessarily the forum to do that and we
are pushing on articulating our case
very strongly through the state parties
and also through the Security Council of
the United Nations which are the
appropriate bodies for us to push that
argument and as I'm sure you're aware we
have articulated our case very clearly
and our position with regard the ICC and
the need for its reform very clearly and
we shall continue to do so so what is
your position do you want to reform the
ICC or do you want to follow the example
of the random foreign minister who said
here on DW that African countries should
leave the International Criminal Court
we want reform but we are also equally
prepared to say that we shall leave if
we don't get the necessary reforms that
we require but we are seeing it as a
court that is not actually fulfilling
the mandate that it was supposed to feel
when the statute itself was first
conceived getting more German investors
to come to Kenya is another key
objective of your trip and that's the
most important component of our trip
because we believe that we have very
strong partnership with with Germany we
already have a large number of German
companies already invested in Kenya and
doing very good business in Kenya and we
want to see that increase and that was
part of the reason why we are here to
engage on my particular issue with
Chancellor Merkel and also to engage
with the business fraternity of Germany
with a view of expanding and increasing
investment but also trade between our
two countries what can you tell German
investors who might be interested to
invest in Kenya but who are scared of
the high corruption rates we are saying
that Kenya is
moving very fast in terms of reforming
its doing business indicators and one of
those of course is corruption and this
is an issue that we are taking head-on
we are tackling as I'm sure you've seen
a number of senior ministers and public
servants have already been arrested we
are strengthening our laws working again
also with private sector creating a new
bribery bill that we have worked in
conjunction with private sector that
criminalizes a bribery from both the
point of the giver as well as the taker
and strengthening the institutions that
we have to fight corruption currently
today for the first time since we've put
all this together we have a large number
of cases already before courts awaiting
determination on corruption so Kenya is
seriously addressing this issue and I
believe we are making very good progress
in that particular fight and on regional
peace and stability the issue of
fighting the Islamist a Shabaab militia
in Somalia was also high on the agenda
of your talks here I believe what
additional support from Germany and
Europe would you want we are all looking
at this and recognizing today that we
are not fighting national Wars terrorism
is not a national battle it's a global
battle and we need far greater far
greater cooperation from a point of view
of intelligence sharing from a point of
view of dealing with the radicalization
from a point of view of dealing with the
causes of extremism and this cannot be
done by any one single country alone and
I think there is growing agreement that
we need to strongly partner going
forward as well as working with Germany
in this case for example to strengthen
and help our own security forces fight
this battle better while we also
increase our cooperation in terms of
intelligence sharing
because as you know terrorism has no
boundaries so we who fight terrorism
must also not have boundaries but must
be able to share in order to for us to
have an ultimate victory in this battle
the excellency thank you very much for
the interview